to be honest I've kind of had sort of an
American point of view whenever thinking
about it it's now that Andrew Tate's
converted it's really changed my mind
towards the whole religion I'm
definitely going to look into it I've
nothing against Islam you're going to
look into it but you're not you're not
turning your back
is are you
from today my dear brothers and sisters
there's been this YouTuber his name is
Sony Fez uh forgive me if I'm wrong but
this brother he was watching the
reversion with uh his mother the the
entertain River story with Muhammad
hijab and let's just say let's just say
things got a little interesting so let's
put it on and let's see what happens all
right Andrew Tate recently converted to
Islam to be honest I've kind of had sort
of an American point of view whatever
thinking about it it's now that Andrew
Tate's converted it's really changed my
mind towards the whole religion and I'm
definitely gonna look into it I have
nothing against Islam you're going to
look into it but you're not turning
you're back on Jesus are you I'm just
saying I'm like I'm gonna do research
into it because if he is going into that
religion and I value his word so much
with everything else he's saying I'm
assuming it it means something listen
nothing against it you're Sicilian well
I think a lot of people have been
following me for a while understand that
I've been very respectful of Islam for a
long time I was born in a Christian
country I was raised as a Christian and
I've always been very respectful of
Islam and it's become more and more
obvious to me and and more and more
pertinent that Islam is the last
religion on the planet when I talk about
Islam because I'm new to it yeah I I'm a
little bit careful right because I'm new
to it I'm certainly not a scholar
there's so much I need to learn I know
I'm on a Learning Journey I'm not here
to sit there and talk scripture I don't
know those things yet I'm here to learn
but we're here at your assistance thank
you brother thank you thank you but um
it's just for me it feels like the last
religion on Earth I feel like there's no
other religion people say to me why did
you convert I said I don't really feel
it as a conversion I it's almost like I
knew God was real and now I've become
religious and they say well you're
religious before I was like religious
before how Christian what does Christian
mean like who's not a Christian you go
to Christian nations and everyone says
they're a Christian look how they live
their lives go into the average church
is anyone actually fearful of God
anybody no the girls are out on Saturday
night drinking and they turn up to
church because their parents made them
but there's there's no substance to the
religion and also
Islam very closely reflects my personal
beliefs I through my personal life I've
learned that if you don't have standards
and you're not a strong person who's
prepared to defend his ideas you will be
crushed yes and we look at most
religions in the world today which are
not prepared to defend their ideas
what's happened to them they're just
getting crushed and now we have
Christianity as an idea which is
basically said well we can't set any
firm rules because everyone will just
quit so instead let's make it so easy to
be a Christian that nobody has to put
any effort in and then accept everybody
no matter what and hopefully we can keep
the church doors open do you not agree
with him to an extent with like this
religion I see why he thinks that I mean
I can see my in my youth so I I made all
of my sacraments in the Catholic church
but we didn't go to church every Sunday
we didn't sit at the kitchen table at
night and talk about the Bible or
biblical principles or or the stories
and how we can apply them to our own
lives we didn't we were like we phoned
it in all of it but it was extremely
important like when you had your baptism
communion confirmation every single
thing was so important and you had to
have a big party and the whole family
had to be there and we had to make a
fuss and you got all new clothes and
that day was was critical in your as a
stepping stone in growing up yet we
didn't really that was it that was yeah
you had a day where you put clothes on
like that's kind of his point and so so
I I do see his point though I now am a
practicing Christian and it is so very
important to me and so part of my daily
life like there's things that go on like
while you're sleeping you know I'm on
the Bible app and I listen to the verse
the the verse of the day and then I read
the devotional and I listen to like
certain Christian artists songs that
really helped me feel connected and I go
to church and you know since we moved to
Florida I'm on the hunt for a new church
because I missed the one I fell in love
with in Boston so I'm a different kind
of Christian than the one he's talking
about for him to just make a
generalization about the whole religion
that the whole religion is is kind of
foolish so I think she actually makes a
decent point
um but I think it's important to look at
the whole picture when you look at
Christians generally she said that it's
it's wrong for him to generalize and I'd
say for the most part we shouldn't
generalize unless that the statement is
generally true like if I were to say
well humans have you know uh two hands
well generally most humans have two
hands now every single human being I
don't think anyone would have a problem
with me saying generally
um humans have two hands so same thing
with Christians when you look at
generally at the people who claim to be
Christian and I know that some
Christians are going to be of a certain
denomination and say everyone else is
not Christian I understand that but when
you look at majority of people who who
claim to be Christian who are who are
active and practicing by their standards
or whatever most of them including the
pope himself are reluctant to say
something like homosexuality is a sin
the pope recently said that it's okay to
be gay the pope himself said that so
when the pope himself who is supposed to
be a a world-class kind of uh Divine not
Divine figure but you know kind of
arbitrator of the word of God and
explainer of the word of God
and deliver of the message of God saying
things like that then of course everyone
else is going to kind of fold
on those things we look at Christianity
as a whole all throughout history it was
always changing it was never a solid
thing when you look at the Bible that we
have today even though it's not
preserved let's let's just say for the
sake of argument what is in the Bible
today is is is true
and there are some things you can argue
are true or false but regardless
Jesus it's recorded in the Bible that he
said he did not come to abolish the law
he came to fulfill it
when Paul went to the non-jews the
Romans and the Gentiles he abolished the
law for them because if they knew that
okay we have to circumcise our children
we can't drink we can't eat pork we
can't uh be adulterers we can't commit
sins they're not going to accept it so
he boiled the religion down to just
accept Jesus died for your sins
so who really betrayed Jesus who's
really betraying Jesus the one that
looks into Islam or Paul himself
Paul went against uh James who became
who was who was basically the brother of
Jesus who became the head of the temple
when Jesus left
and he disagreed with Paul so who's
really betraying Jesus is it is it is it
your son or anyone who's looking into
Islam or is it Paul himself
is it people who came and they're saying
certain things are not a sin all of a
sudden even though it's very explicit in
the Bible the Old end or new testament
that certain things are prohibited who's
really betraying Jesus now let's take it
a step further let's take it a step
further Jesus never actually claimed to
be God Jesus never actually claimed to
be God we discussed it before
and I'll show the whole book this time
insha Allah
the five gospels we've discussed that
book before we know Jesus never actually
came to be God this is a valid
historical
opinion about Scholars like Martin have
but he never claimed to be God but there
was a point where he was made to be
divine by other people later on and
certain words report in his mouth that
he never said so who's really betraying
Jesus if Jesus came and he said worship
God Alone
which is why he said he came he said
even recording the Bible if you believe
it to be true he said John in John 17 3.
so that they may know you the only true
God talking to the Father and Jesus
Christ when we have sent Jesus himself
the son is referring to God as the only
true God or the father is the only true
God
many verses the father is greater than I
so on and so forth where you have to
conclude in any logical and rational
matter
that Jesus is not God nor did he claim
to be God but he worshiped the father
alone and called others to worship God
alone that's exactly what Islam says
that's exactly what Islam says and it's
it's recorded in the Quran on the day of
judgment God will ask Jesus did you tell
people to worship gods or you and your
mother beside me as gods and Jesus Will
decline he'll say no I never said that
and in Surah atoba in the Quran Allah he
says
that the Christians say Jesus the
Messiah is the son of Mary
is the son of God
and they're just repeating lies that the
disbelievers before them have said
how do you today actually know Jesus
said these things
you don't
and if he didn't you're repeating lies
that people have said before so who's
really betraying Jesus here if anyone
wants to be just to Jesus from a
religious scriptural standpoint then
they would have to be Muslim because
Islam is the only religion that accepts
Jesus as the Messiah
so it doesn't negate him being a
prophetic or or
Messianic messenger
but it doesn't
make him God it doesn't put him above
who he actually is and ruin his message
so the only real answer is Islam if
we're being honest
100 percent
keep it going boy and
ignore it I think all to me is is strong
God to me is something to be feared God
to me something someone that people are
afraid to mock yeah God to me is someone
that you have to go out of your way to
prove something to God to me has red
lines like God to me represents the
Islamic faith the Christian God to me I
don't see God I can't explain I don't
see anything there so to me it was it
was the only logical Choice
I'm sure many people are like ecstatic
and extremely happy it's a great it's a
great thing for everyone honestly
because you know just anyone coming into
Islam is you know the prophet Muhammad
is better than the world and everything
in it yeah but imagine now somebody of
major influence I mean you're the most
Googled person on the planet yeah I
think Putin might have beat me as of
last week but I think it's between me
and Putin at the moment but I don't want
to lose Putin's the Big G I don't want
more enemies like it's fine Vladimir you
can have it I never thought I'd hear you
saying that statement yeah
it's definitely something beautiful and
a lot of people have you know you'll be
surprised at how many women as well like
because obviously the the accusations of
misogyny stuff which you know but but a
lot of women especially in the Muslim
world they're absolutely happy in fact
let me tell you a story just before I
came here today one um one particular
woman I can't remember her identity but
she's working as a school teacher yep in
London and um actually my friend told me
that she was uh kicked out of school
yeah because they had this campaign
against you in the schools I'm not sure
if you're aware of it yeah this was part
of the cancellation I didn't know about
this yeah so in British schools they
said you know if you say anything good
about if you if you say anything good
about this person or you have to be
reported or prevented and if you say
anything you know you have to kind of
combat his extremism or whatever maybe
right so she because when you became
Muslim she abstained from doing that she
said I can't really do that because you
know Islamic laws and it's it's
backbiting and he's got honor and Islam
and so on and unfortunately
wow so you can see that this is the
level of encroachment we're talking
about here so and this shows you that
the level of fraternity that exists and
not only the fact that you know when
you're looking at Old Twitter or
whatever Twitter or whatever social
media it's not a representation of
what's really happening of course of
course and I I mean that's that's crazy
to hear and what's most crazy is
yeah the further behind this idea that
I'm somehow extremist is truly
it's truly clown world like I've sat as
a professional and analyzed my content
and understood which things can be taken
out of context and which things were
said in a way perhaps they wouldn't
shouldn't have been said before I was
massively famous but we have to sit here
and understand that if you take anybody
on the planet and give them seven years
of YouTube and then they decide and they
blow up big you're gonna be able to find
30 to 45 seconds of clip across all
those years that could be taken out of
context right yeah and and and and it's
truly crazy because they sit and say oh
yeah but you know the young boys are
watching your stuff and they don't truly
understand all of it and it there's
Nuance that's missing and my argument is
very simple my argument is well one
you're taking small Clips out of context
and two there's not a single piece of
content on the internet that 14 year old
boy can't misunderstand name somebody
name someone who's producing content on
the internet that you would be a hundred
percent happy for a 14 year old artists
so they say that I mean I live in an
area this I'm not going to mention the
names of the artists but they're talking
about going to this I know it is ironic
because then you just push rap and
murder and all this horrible [ __ ] on
these kids and then you're like
entertain is the one that's that's yeah
the devil there was a time I was an
atheist there was a time when I was
atheistic and the reason I am now so
absolutely certain that God is real is
because I've seen evil I've seen shaytan
I've seen it when you see enough evil
you realize that there must be an equal
and opposite force and there are people
out there in the world today doing the
work of the devil genuine demons who are
trying to destroy the Baseline morality
that's inside of all of us we're all
born with some kind of morality and
they're trying to destroy it and that's
exactly the Islamic understanding that
we believe that you're born with
something called fitra which is the
initial goodness you're you're born with
an innate belief receptivity to believe
in one God and then that is corrupted in
fact there's a prophet Hadith where he
says
every born child is born upon this
initial goodness
and then his for father and mother or
his parents they socialize him into you
know Christianity days of magism so the
idea is that everyone is born with this
initial goodness and this initial will
or want to believe in God one God and
then as you mentioned I mean it's what
you're mentioning here is really is
profound because you're you're
mentioning a central Doctrine in Islam
if that is true and that that's a I
think that's a lovely belief I really
like that if that is true that all
people all humans are born with that
then what what happens is you know like
these Christians who he's talking about
who are totally lost and and have no
connection to their religion or any
religion or any God and they talk about
it but it's all just lip service you
know they they have that's still in them
and they have a chance to come back to
that I mean he he himself is 30
something years old and now just coming
to this so who is he to to pass judgment
on the Christians oh yeah I don't like
that and I saw the Quran and it
confirmed okay I think it's I think it's
fair to um to discuss that point a
little bit
um do you want to start or should I uh
get into it
Google first bro all right so firstly I
want to say um just just I don't want to
say correction because I don't want to
start with uh correcting entertain
online and that stuff because I think
that can be very problematic but just
for anyone who might misunderstand
because Muhammad didn't say anything we
don't believe that shaytan is is equal
to Allah in any way so when he says
there has to be an equal opposite Force
to evil
we actually we don't believe like if
you're looking at like you know God
being a force of good in in shaytan
being a force of evil they're not equal
Allah is there's no comparison to him
there's nothing even you know similar to
him or close them or comparable in any
way Allah could destroy shaython uh 10
billion years ago and then create them
again destroy them again and do it and
as many times Allah Wills shaytan has no
power all he does is he whispers to us
and tries to entice us to do evil and
any good is from Allah and any evils
from shaytan ourselves so there's no
equality there just but I I don't think
that's the main point he's making the
main points that there's evil therefore
there needs to be something good
something enticing us to do good and um
the point that um uh Sunny's mom is
making if I understood it correctly is
that since he is now coming to this kind
of like you know belief in God and and
doing good and in this real genuine
belief in Allah and belief to do good
then he shouldn't pass judgment on the
Christians the difference is he's not
coming to Christianity we believe that
the goodness is that you follow the
prophet Muhammad and you accept Allah
you worship one God alone and you accept
his religion which is Islam so even if a
Christian had this Awakening where they
want to be a good person we don't
believe they actually have the the
knowledge of the scripture to do that
because when they go to the Bible they
get a whole uh conglomerate uh like
conglomerate or a multitude of different
views and verses and things that maybe
even contradict each other when you come
to Islam you get one kind of coherent
way okay one very easy system of Life
Worship one God alone and join good and
forbid evil and it's very clear what's
good and what's evil and and so on and
so forth so that's what he's coming to
the Christians nowadays even if someone
wants to say okay let me practice and
dedicate my life to God what do they do
really what do they do
because if we're being real they don't
drink they don't smoke they don't have
an intercourse before marriage they they
they don't say anything like holy
F or holy whatever swear words
you know
how many of those people actually exist
and even those people how many of them
can you you know refute the idea of the
Trinity to which didn't come till 300
years later
using the Bible itself
so there's I think a multitude of
problems
hmm
okay so I wanna I wanna speak on the
point the Sony's mom was uh making in
Sony if
you're watching this and I'm saying the
name wrong please forgive me bro uh but
what I want to say is that your mom may
notice about the point of like you know
people coming back to uh the religion
coming back to God and now Andrew Taylor
is coming back to God uh 30 something
years old and how your own mom she came
back and she's you know really
practicing and all that stuff
let's keep it very simple all right
let's keep things very simple
we all have an innate state
that is almost like this moral compass
it lets us know what's good
and what's bad
okay in Islam this is called the fitra
every single human
is born with the fitra the internal
state that moral compass you look at a
kid a kid is innocent a kid is intact
with this moral compass with the fitra
Okay so
the easiest way to understand
the easiest way to understand if okay
which religion is actually it which path
is actually here
listen just put the religions in front
of kids
see see what the kids say see which one
the kids
um begin to lean towards to see which
one the kids begin to ask questions and
the answers are made very simple for the
kids
listen like I grew up in Catholicism
I have many friends who grew up in
Christianity I later went into
Christianity before I became Muslim like
it's not simple my God
Christianity is not simple
Catholicism is not simple
and they do a very good job of just
mixing everything up
complicating it so again if you want to
keep it simple take a kid who has the
fit that are intact and see what they
lean towards see where they gravitate to
because the more you look into Islam
which I highly highly suggest and advise
you to look into Islam who am I to
advise you but I'm known
just take take what's being said and
take it with you do something with it
but I I highly suggest that you look
into Islam because in Islam it's known
that it's it's the natural religion
right it's the only religion that
coincides with the national religion and
the natural religion is
is going to go into the natural religion
so I'm gonna I'm gonna I think I've said
a little too much but I hope you get the
point
so many things for me you know like even
the conversations I've been having so
far so many things have been confirmed
and it's amazing the knowledge that's
inside of it which is so applicable
today yeah for for an old book right you
know it's supposed to be old but it
seems so so Timeless but it's truly
amazing but you're you're totally right
and the Baseline morality I don't think
most people understand that when they're
doing this under the guise of Tolerance
when they're saying be so tolerant that
you no longer believe in right from
wrong they're not doing that to make
Society a better place they're doing
that to empty your brain so that you
have no resistance to the slave mind
programming they want to get you to a
point where if they tell you the sky is
green yeah you look at with your own
eyes yeah and you see blue but no the
sky is green that's what they want so
that you have to have nothing in your
brain that can prevent that if you have
God if you have no I believe this is
right and wrong if you have personal
responsibility if you have
self-accountability if you're a person
who sticks up for what he believes all
that's bad to them they want all of that
gone so they can tell you the sky is
green this may be a loaded statement
because I don't fully understand what
I'm talking about but maybe the
Christians the legit Christians and the
Muslims should get together you know for
political purposes collab stream they're
gonna collab they need to get together
and join forces and be able to you know
really stand for Traditional Values even
doesn't because it truly doesn't matter
if you're following the Quran or you're
following a true biblical principles
they're very similar and there's a lot
there's enough similarity that we can
stand together to create traditional
solid values in a
I don't want to cut her off but actually
I think that's a very fair point but
wait
okay I don't want to cut her off but I
think that's a very fair point because
actually there's something there's some
basis for that in the Quran where Allah
I don't know the exact Ayah or what it
exactly says but I'm going to paraphrase
a little bit he says basically come to
like you know uh some kind of agreement
with the people of the booker kind of
get together and what you guys agree
upon you know that you worship one God
alone and so on and so forth and I think
there is some basis to what she's saying
but at the same time I don't think the
the the differences are minimal enough
for us to be able to band together
because I mean what are you really
fighting for let's let's question that
what are you fighting for are you
fighting for the freedom of religion
let me tell you why that's that's
problematic especially from an Islamic
perspective because you're you're
fighting to have the freedom to believe
what you want within a non-muslim uh
system islamically we're not really
supposed to live in a non-muslim system
or a non-muslim world you can if need be
which you know today's day and age
that's what we have
but to be fighting for the right to what
belief what you believe within a
non-muslim world and to get together
with Christians and Jews and and
everyone who actually has different
beliefs
for that purpose that's I don't want to
say half ass but that's kind of
I think that's a useless battle to be
completely honest
because that aims to just be living here
under non-muslims forever and what's
going to happen 30 years from now 100
years from now they're gonna do the same
exact thing they're gonna continue to
progress with their secular liberal
um ideology and their their their
left-leaning political beliefs
and we're gonna just be left in the dust
religiously speaking and they've already
got this far think about it they've
already gotten so far to make us secular
do you know how big that is they have
made us secular they have divided our
religion from the state from the laws
from the practices
they've divided our religion already so
what are you asking for oh please don't
take a mate away what are you fighting
for please don't take away my right to
believe that homosexuality is a sin
is that how bad it's gotten
then think about what they did the past
100 200 300 years when they were
secularizing the religions
there's a reason there's a reason why
Muslims think that
you know believing in God worshiping God
is just praying and fasting and that's
it
that's not all it is you have an entire
way of life given to you by God you have
to obey God every step of the way every
decision you have in life you must be
asking yourself what decision would
please God what decision would displease
God
that's how we need to live
but unfortunately we can't fully live
that way in the west and I think that's
the bigger conversation that needs to be
had and culture again instead of all
this [ __ ] Madness that's turning it's
sending us down the toilet it's sitting
here [ __ ] on Christianity if he
really cared about those values he would
look around and say who can I align
myself with who can I who can I align
with to make sure that these values that
we save Society together understand why
like the thing is though I understand
exactly why he's saying it I hope his
next step in his in his evolution is to
say and maybe this isn't in the Muslim
religion I don't know there's I know
[ __ ] and the Islamic is to come his next
step as a Muslim is to say who can
realign ourselves with to create the
world that we believe we want even if
they aren't they don't respond to our
religion and and you know what maybe
this religion it's like if you're not
one of us like everybody's everybody's
burning in hell no I hear both sides I I
definitely do but um from what I take
from what he's saying is like if he has
to pick a religion he's going to pick to
a religion
yeah and and it's they're trying to
program us all into slaves I remember
when I was in my undergraduate days and
I was uh reading a particular book by
this guy called Jeremy Bentham who
became like you know the spiritual
forefather of Joe Smith who is the
father of like social liberalism of
today and I remember reading this
because it was so powerful because it
linked to something I read in the Quran
he said that you know you have two gods
he said you have the god of pain and you
have the God of Pleasure and I thought
this is so interesting the Quran States
you know
have you seen the one who takes his own
desires as a God and because now there
is no transcendental force that we can
look up and as you say venerate now
we're forced to be slaves to the system
yeah we're to our own desires or I mean
the Quran has another verse which I
think is so powerful and it connects
very well with what you're saying
that God has struck a parable of a man
that he's got many different slave
owners
and another kind of man who's only got
one slave owner he's God is basically
telling us in the Quran that you've got
one example of one individual who's got
multiple slave owners and another one
with just one he says are they the same
so here the idea is
as Rousseau said that his liberal
philosophy said that man is Born Free
but everywhere in Chains
this is the order because if you don't
have that God to to worship then you're
going to end up having to worship to
everything else and the whole part of
the shahada which you took which is
[ __ ] that's crazy what's crazy no if you
if you know this already you came to
church with me and you heard I think it
was two or three weeks in a row sermons
from JD about idolatry and about
worshiping false gods and how they're
they're never gonna they're never gonna
fulfill you you're always gonna fall
short nothing's ever going to work that
is exactly the same thing as here which
kind of proves my point that we have
parallels no yeah 100 I definitely see
all this but oh right you're bugging out
on it again you forgot I gotta remind
you we're gonna take you back and change
the recordings of JD talking about that
listen
no disrespect against your mother bro
I'm Allah blessing
I don't even know if I can say that to
um people who are not Muslim but
what I want to say here
is that you said oh wow that's crazy
because in the Quran it's made very
simple whereas in Christianity when
you're going to church and you have a
pastor and he's giving sermons and he's
talking about things and he's linking it
to maybe his day-to-day life experiences
or someone that he's talked to in their
experience and stuff like that it's not
the same
it's not the same as when God is
speaking you directly through these
verses bro that's why when Muhammad
hijab is just mentioning something from
the Quran it's already making you say
whoa like damn that that's crazy yes it
is crazy boy so again no disrespect to
you Mom
it's just something to think about
yeah 100 and especially like I I don't
want to take it too deep but think about
it like this there are two aspects to
worshiping God there's you know praying
to believing in and and all that stuff
and then there's obedience
in Islam if you you know pray to God but
you don't obey him and you obey somebody
or something else instead of God knowing
that you're taking them over God then
that person I'm speaking generally here
can't be a Muslim they're not a Muslim
but in Christianity
if you believe in the sacrifice of Jesus
Christ and you believe in the Trinity
and and I'm speaking generally again
here because like there's different
um denominations but generally if you
believe that stuff that's enough for you
you will go to heaven just based on that
you can obey Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory if you want to bro you
can obey anyone you can obey your
desires you can be whatever as long as
you believe in Jesus and his sacrifice
and The Trinity you're good you're going
to heaven in Islam it's not that clear
it's not that simple actually it's more
clear but it's not that simple the
reason is because we need accountability
as human beings who is holding you
accountable
if all you need to do is believe and
you're going to heaven where's the
accountability and this is the question
because I don't know I don't know their
beliefs but to Sonny and his mom just
think about this question
first let me say the Islamic stance if a
person is a Muslim and they commit a sin
against someone else you know like they
murder somebody and then later they
repent and and they want to be better
if they genuinely repent to be better
Allah will forgive them but the person
that they killed they will owe something
to them on the day of judgment to make
it fair to make it right
that's how just Islam is that Allah is
so merciful he can forgive you but you
still may all Adept that person unless
they forgive you as well right and
that's a whole other level of of
beautiful you know forgiveness in Islam
if another Muslim is willing to forgive
you
right in Christianity it doesn't matter
who you killed it doesn't matter what
happened even if it was another
Christian to be fair both those people
will be in heaven generally speaking uh
especially if you're going based on the
Catholic view if they believe in Jesus
Christ as sacrifice in the trinity
do you think that is something that is
fair do you think that is something that
that allows Christians to hold
themselves accountable
or do you think it's better that in
Islam for example we have uh sayings of
the companions of the Prophet like hold
yourself accountable before you're held
to account by Allah
just think about that
and I hope they react to this inshallah
and well his mom's saying that there's
parallels
in the the Bible and in the Quran listen
if you read the Quran uh God says very
clearly
that
I know I don't even copy it
uh gases very clearly
the Quran
is just the final
testing okay then you had the Old
Testament which was the Torah
you have the New Testament nowadays
then you have the final testament which
is the Quran the Quran is coming in
literally saying exactly what was said
in the Torah exactly what was said in
the Bible in the gospel in what Jesus
was coming with but you know what
it's been altered
it's been altered it's been changed
that's why God has come back and I've
said this multiple to multiple multiple
times it's like the telephone game you
know you you say something in someone's
ear and then you have to go around they
have to keep saying in the other
person's ear in a circle and then by the
time it gets to you if if it's changed
if it's no longer the same message okay
game over you start over right but if
it's the same message then that's it
you're done you didn't okay the game is
done right
that's been trying to do that since day
one all right now when God sends a
message if it's changed then God comes
back with a message to another group or
just another person in general
like this is why you've seen what you've
seen and if you actually look into Islam
if you look into the Quran this is God
bringing back the same message but this
time it's the last time that he's
bringing it back he's bringing it to the
prophet Muhammad and the prophet
Muhammad is known as the basically the I
think it's the the prophetic seal he is
the last
prophet he is the final prophet and what
this means is that if he is the final
one then he
not only did he complete the message
but it means
it means it hasn't been altered
since the the time that it's come into
this reality
I just take that just really take that
and do your own research with it bro
you came home and you talked about it in
the middle of the week you you remember
I remember you saying you were thinking
about it it's an excellent point it is I
just think especially like a lot of
regular churches is just like I don't
get anything out of it yeah the church
we went to my home was good yeah I know
but like for the most time like most of
the time it's just like some old ass
dude reading reading something that you
can't even hear um wow and you gotta
stand up you gotta sing your songs and
it's just like what like what I didn't
gain anything from this spiritually
could have read a book and and had more
insight right but but to look at it and
understand and as you get older you
understand that that's just one
experience of it oh yeah I'm sure that
there's something you know and that's
why I'm on the hunt for the right church
here in Florida but kind of into three
so far because they're all different and
you've got to find the one that that
gets you where you're trying to go with
it but yes sitting and listening to
requesting 99 year old man may be a
great experience but gets it gets a
little it gets a little uh boring
sometimes and I don't know I had okay
quick point I think I think it's it's
very fair for her to understand that it
can get boring sometimes and 100 it's
not always going to be fun I don't think
religion is always supposed to be
something that is fun it's supposed to
be something that is true that is that
gives you contentment that is endearing
that is spiritually lifting but it's not
always going to be fun but at the same
time um she said something and I don't
want to play like you know semantics but
I think it's important to call it out
she mentioned that basically she's
trying to go to the right church that
that's bringing her to where she wants
to go
but I think that's problematic because
now that the focus is on you and what
you want
so if you go back to the eye in the
Quran have you seen the one who takes uh
you know their desire as their own God
how would you not be falling and not her
specific because I think everyone is
like this generally speaking in the west
how are you not making your desires
you're gone you're saying I want to get
to this destination let me find the
means that will bring me there why are
you not saying let me find the truth let
me find what God wants from me let me
obey whatever it is he sends down and if
that's Islam that's Islam if that's not
it's something else if it's Christianity
okay but let me find the truth with
evidence and rationality and logic and
proof and then let me follow what God
wants from me
that is how we need to be as human
beings because we're not the the the the
main point we're not the object uh we
are the subject
I I found Catholicism I love it as a
culture because we're Italian and I love
the gold and the glitz of it but I also
find found it to be like very
disconnecting from God and very like he
says God should be feared and I'm like
that's what they did and I didn't it
didn't do anything for me I like the god
that like wants to sit down next to me
and get me through my [ __ ] and that's
where what I found with the Baptists so
I'm interesting this is interesting
because I like learning more about the
Muslims let's see what else they got to
say
that the true meaning of that is that
there is no God worthy of worship except
for one God which means that your your
desires or the system or these people
that want to control us they are the
problem is they're not worthy of worship
the only one worthy of our subordination
and submission is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth there's no one
else I agree and it's it's like a
Christian I completely agree and I've
agreed with this for the longest time
you know I've never been to like a music
concert and people ask me why I said I
just look at it and I feel embarrassed I
look at someone up on a stage dancing
around and I look at hundreds of
thousands of peasants in the crowd just
yeah yeah yeah I'm like it's embarrass I
feel cringe it's like secondhand
embarrassment when I see these festivals
and everyone's losing their mind or
these music concerts what did I tell you
after I went to Rolling loud in New York
City oh you I think you said it was like
you just felt like a an NPC is that
right yeah I said I felt like a bot
after seeing card and I told you going
to festivals and stadiums sucks it's no
way to see music going to a club and
theater shows you're really taking in a
different level of entertainment that is
very much more personal so he's not
wrong in in half the cases no not at all
genuinely feel embarrassed for the
people who go because to me that is a
form of worship like yeah you can listen
to the music at home for free like you
don't have to wait in that line and
stand out in the cold I don't know
perhaps it was a bit extreme but I've
always known that they're trying to give
us false Idols to some degree and when I
speak to atheists atheists think oh I
don't believe in God but they they've
signed up so hard to the liberal woke
agenda they're as religious as anybody
but they're just believing in the wrong
things they're believing in degeneracy
and they're believing in the work of the
devil so humans always need something to
believe in and it's a great thing you
said about your own desires it's like
one one guy I was talking to since my
conversion says it's interesting that
somebody with everything all the Western
World yeah I think everything somebody
could want is that has now converted and
I said yeah because even before my
conversion I understood that Hedonism is
a black hole and you can never fill it
you're never going to be able to have
enough girls to be happy with girls
you're never gonna be able to have
enough money to be happy with money you
know be able to you know drink enough to
be happy with drinking like it's a black
hole and you can pour endless things
down it but you'll never fill it up and
you need to have some degree of
self-restraint and I've always been a
very disciplined person I've never made
mistakes but certainly yeah the higher
power is is going to give you more
satisfaction in your heart than endless
endless Insanity so do you have any
final thoughts for for entertain
converting to the Islamic faith I don't
know I I just wish he would be easier on
Christians because you know we're out
here and not all of us are uh it's just
NPCs in the Christian World some of us
are are working hard it's the opposite
of an NPC a main character yeah some of
us are main characters out here trying
to try kind of trying to change things
and trying to make the world a better
place slow down on the generalizations
because it's just as unfair as me saying
that Muslims are all terrorists
it's just as ignorant like I do agree
with him about a lot of the way like the
Christian faith is where it's just not
fall to like the extent that Muslims
follow the Islamic faith thank you guys
so much for watching make sure to join
the Discord in my bio so you can post
stuff for us to react to and I also have
some of my free social media tips there
for you to check out right
firstly I want to say that again
generalizations I personally believe
generalizations are are okay if the
thing you're saying is generally true
right and that goes back to the example
with the humans in the hands I gave
before
um it's not exactly Fair
um it's not equivalent
um you know
saying that all Muslims are are
terrorists or whatever because it's not
generally true
to say that Muslims you know generally
believe in God okay that would be
absolutely true
to say anything about Christian
Christians okay that's absolutely true
as well because it is generally true
will you find one weird all that says
I'm a Muslim but I don't believe in God
you'll find that person the same thing
with Christianity you'll find that
person but it's not generally true
um but I do want to say I I think his
mom has a very very good heart I think
her heart's in the right place but I
think she's making the mistake of you
know going going to going to the doctor
No actually that's that's a fair mistake
I think she's making a mistake of going
to a lawyer because she has a toothache
you know what I mean she wants this
spiritual connection she wants the God
where she can go and she can you know
basically plead to and pray to and it's
gonna give her contentment it's gonna
give her a good Community it's gonna
give her a good feeling sense of
belonging and it's going to be the truth
but she's going to Christianity and I
think that with all due respect time and
time again throughout history it's been
demonstrated that Christianity is just
not that it's mainly been a political
thing and the only religiosity that that
it has is some kind of spiritual you
know Jesus died for my sin and that's
very beautiful and I'm going to pray to
God and then I'm going to go live my
worldly life and basically forget about
it till the next time I need to pray to
God for most people it's become that
Islam does not allow that to happen for
Muslims Islam does not allow that to
happen for Muslims you will find Muslims
that don't practice
um you will find Muslims and I'm trying
to say that there aren't Muslims that
you know that don't practice them what
I'm trying to say is that in Islam you
have statements the prophet for example
he said that basically uh the the
border the bridge between belief and
disbelief is leaving your prayer if you
leave your your five daily prayers then
are you even a Muslim at this point and
that's a very very bold thing to say but
it keeps Muslims in check that I need to
continue to practice this religion so I
genuinely think what she's looking for
she will find it in this step and I
think that her and her son they should
both go to Friday jerma and they should
listen to the unless you look at the
Muslims and engage with the Muslims and
I generally think they they'd find a
huge spiritual whole being filled
inshallah
no inshallah
that's beautiful the years you got to
that point because I wanted to bring it
back to this point
where he's like I I invite both
some
damn cough Sony and his mom to
look into Islam
come to Islam and I'll end it with this
beautiful story because she's she's
talking a lot about her emotions and and
what she wants to feel when she goes
into this church and how she wants to be
um have this God that's there for her
like sitting next to her helping her get
through things
I'm not gonna say anything on that but
just think about this okay
and this land is a story where one of
the companions
of the Prophet peace and blessing be
upon him
he
went to Du Hajj
and Hajj is the pilgrimage it's
something that is obligatory upon every
single Muslim before you die
okay now his mother was paralyzed
now the mother in Islam
is like the rate that she has
is just the top of the top because the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him he was asked like who's the
most important person in this world
he said your mother and they're like
okay who's the second most important
person in this world he said your mother
and they said oh okay who's the third
person he's like your mother and there's
and then they're like all right but
who's the fourth person he's like your
father
so the mother is is held to such a high
degree and not just a mother but women
in general all right but the point I
want to make is the mother the mother's
health to a very very high degree in
Islam
it's literally said that the
the Gates of Heaven
are at the feet like the footsteps of
our mother so if if our mother is
pleased with us that's a very good sign
that
God is also pleased with us okay now
with that being said in the story this
companion's mother she was very very
sick
and she couldn't she couldn't walk
okay she couldn't watch she was so sick
she couldn't walk so what he did is he
put her on his back
and he performed
Hajj he performed the pilgrimage
around the Kaaba which is the the sacred
Holy House in Mecca
okay he performed this
seven times
and if you actually look into it has
like this is not an easy thing it's not
just like doing like a circle of no no
it's it's a lot that you have to do it's
not just going around the the sacred
house the kava right so
he did it seven times and he went to a
scholar and he asked he said have I
fulfilled the rights upon my mother
by putting her on my back and doing Hajj
seven times with her on my back
the scholarly said not even this much
not even this much of your rights upon
your mother that you fulfill
so that goes to show like not only the
status that our mothers have in Islam
but just just the beauty of it all you
know so like if she's over here talking
about
um she wants this to like be the best
feel for her she wants God so I really
you know be next to her and help her get
past like what's going on they got look
look at this story like God is putting
the highest of value on you on you as
the mother like is that not more
beautiful than anything you've ever
heard before and if it is okay don't
worry about it this forgot but if it
isn't if this is something that's very
beautiful then I highly highly invite
you and your son to come
come to Islam look into Islam do Rami
said go toward listen to what's being
said ask questions listen
to the recitation of the Quran because
that's
that's what the beauty is
you know God bless you and your son
I love my I mean and with that being
said Allah
foreign